if we can go back just briefly so 44
years ago like you mentioned
40 plus years ago you've written animal
liberation the classic book that started
that uh launched it was the foundation
of the movement
of animal liberation can you summarize
the key set of ideas that underpin that
book
certainly the the key idea that
underlies that book
is the concept of speciesism
which i did not invent that term i took
it from a man called richard ryder who
was in oxford when i was and i saw a
pamphlet that he'd written about
experiments on chimpanzees that used
that term
but i think i contributed to making it
philosophically more precise into
getting it into a broader audience and
the idea is that
we have a bias or a prejudice
against taking seriously the interests
of beings who are not members
of our species just as in the past
europeans for example had a bias against
taking seriously the interests of
africans racism and men have had a bias
against taking seriously the interests
of of women
sexism so i think something analogous
not completely identical but something
analogous
goes on and has gone on for a very long
time with the way humans
see themselves visibly animals we see
ourselves as
more important we see animals as
existing
to serve our needs in various ways and
you can find this very explicit in
earlier philosophers from aristotle
through to kant and others
and either we
don't need to take their interest into
account at all
or we can discount it because they're
not humans
they count a little bit but they don't
count nearly as much as humans do
uh my book argues that that attitude is
responsible for
a lot of the things that we do to
animals that are wrong
confining them indoors in very crowded
cramped conditions in
factory farms to produce meat or eggs or
milk more cheaply
using them in some research that's by no
means
essential for our survival or well-being
uh and a whole lot you know some of the
sports and uh
things that we do to animals so
uh i think that's unjustified because i
think uh
the significance of pain and suffering
does not depend on the species of the
being who is in pain or suffering any
more than it depends on the race or
sex of the being who is in pain or
suffering
and i think we ought to rethink our
treatment of animals
along the lines of saying if the pain is
just as great an animal then it's just
as bad
that it happens as if it were a human
you